وينضم الينا من رام الله نهاد ابو غوش
الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي عندما يتحدث
السيد نهاد ابو غوش يتحدث نتنياهو بانه
يعني امر خطير وتطور
ماساوي ما جرى للرهائن الثلاثه المحتجزين
من قتلهم على ايدي جيش الاحتلال داخل غزه
الى اي مرحله ينقل هذه العمليه
والقرارات الحكوميه
بخصوصها
تحياتي لكم هو يريد ان يبرر عناده وتعنته
في موضوع الاسرى هناك حركه احتجاج واسعه
تطالب ب يعني اعطاء الاولويه القصوى
لتحرير الاسرى ولو على قاعده الكل المقابل
الكل التي تطالب بها المقاومه هذه الحركه
لم تعد تقتصر على اهالي الاسرى
الاسرائيليين بل اتسعت لتشمل فئات
اجتماعيه ومنظمات اهليه ومنظمات حقوق
انسان و يعني اطراف عديده يعني ترفض ال
اسلوب القياده الاسرائيليه في اداره هذه
المعركه خصوصا ان نتنياهو يطارد ويلاحق
نصرا موهوما ويعتقد وهكذا يروج ان الضغط
على حماس هو الذي يؤدي الى الافراج عن
الاسرار على كل حال يعني هناك اكثر من
اربع او خمس مرات ثبت فيها بطلان هذا
الزعم حيث قتل اكثر من اسير اعتقد انه
يعني ليس فقط الثلاثه هؤلاء بل يضاف لهم
على الاقل ثلاث محاولات اخرى كلما حاولت
القوات الاسرائيليه الضغط ومحاصر الاماكن
التي يخفى فيها الاسرى او يحتجز فيها
الاسرى اي تؤدي الى موت الاسرى بل في احدى
المرات قتل واصيب عدد من الجنود
الاسرائيليين اثناء محاولتهم تحريل الاسرى
ثبت انه لا يمكن الافراج عن الاسرى
الاسرائيليين الا بصفقه تبادل ويبدو ان
العقليه الاسرائيليه تفكر احيانا بقتل
الاسرى يعني هذا ثبت بالممارسه ولا اتكه
من باب يعني الظن لكن نعرف ان هناك
بروتوكول او اسلوب عسكري اسمه اسلوب هانب
بال الذي يهدف الى حرمان القوه المعاديه
من ادوات قوتها اي الاسرى وبالتالي تقتل
الاسرى ومن ياسر وهذا ثبت في اكثر من
مناسبه وها هو يتكرر الان يعني اذا
نتنياهو يطارد نصرا موهوما يحاول كل ما في
وسعه الحصول ما جر
للجندي سعر بارخ الذي ذكرته في محاوله
القوه الاسرائيليه الوصول اليه ما ادى الى
مقتله ومقتل ايضا جزء واصابه جزء من
المهاجمين وايضا ما جرى البارحه كيف مع
الضغط الكبير الحاصل في الشارع الاسرائيلي
من قبل اهالي المحتجزين ومن ينضم اليهم في
هذه الدائره التي تتوسع كيف سيؤثر على هذا
الملف وعلى القرارات
الحكوميه يعني يؤثر على انه كلما مضى
نتنياهو وحكومته في هذه الحرب حرب الاباده
كلما ارتكب مزيدا من الاخطاء واضح انه
يحاول اطاله امد الحرب لعله يخرج ب بعض
المنجزات التي يستطيع ان يسوقها فيرفع
شعبيته المتهاوي او يعزز مكانته ب يعني
لعل ان القادم الايام يحمل مزيدا من اي
يعني استعاده مكانته الهابطه باضطراد هذا
الامر بلا شك يعني كلما مضى اكثر ايه
ارتفعت فاتوره الضحايا المدنيين في الشعب
الفلسطيني وهذا يثبت ان الهدف ليس لا
القضاء على حماس ولا استعاده الاسرى الهدف
هو قتل مزيد من المدنيين وهذا تكتيك عسكري
بات مكشوفا ومعروفا ولعل الادعاء الامريكي
بان اسرائيل تمارس القصف العشوائي يحاول
ان يبرر ذلك لانه في بنهايه المطاف هذا
ليس قصوا قصفا عشوائيا بل قصف يهدف الى
الاباده وتدمير كل معالم الحياه الحضاريه
والانسانيه والخدميه والمؤسسات والافراد
وبالتالي جزء من ا ادوات الحرب هو تكبيد
الشعب الفلسطيني ثمنا باهظا جدا جدا حتى
يتكرس في وعي هذا الشعب انه لا يمكن
التصدي لاسرائيل ولا يمكن محاربتها
والخيار الوحيد امام امام الفلسطينيين هو
اما الهجره او الرضوخ لما تريده اسرائيل
ولذلك هذه الحرب اعتقد ان صمود الشعب
الفلسطيني بات خيارا اجباريا لا خيارات
امام الشعب الفلسطيني سو الصمود وال
مقاومه وحتى الان يثبط ان هذا هو ما يجري
ا هذا ما يجري وماذا عن المواقف داخل مجلس
الحرب هل ترصد تصدعا بشان التوجهات
لمتابعه الاهداف ذاتها خاصه هدف استعاده
المحتجزين بذات
الادوات يعني هناك اشارات لكنها لم تصل
بعد الى حد الفراق وال الخلاف على اهداف
الحرب يعني سمعنا بيني جانس الذي يعد
الاكثر اعتدالا في مجلس الحرب بين جانس
يقول انه لابد من اقتطاع جزء من مساحه
قطاع غزه ولا بد من مواصله الحرب اي جلنت
وزير الدفاع يبدو الاكثر تطرفا لانه يمثل
المؤسسه العسكريه التي تهدف الى ترميم
مكانتها واستعاده قوه الردع هناك اهداف
عسكريه يعني خالصه لدى المؤسسه العسكريه
والجيش هم يذهبون باتجاه مزيد من التصعيد
والقصف ومزيد من القتل نتنياهو بين هؤلاء
وهؤلاء يبدو هو يعني انه هو الذي يمسك
يعني يمثل
ال حجر بيضه القبان يعني في هذه المعادله
انا اعتقد هناك اشارات طفيفه لخلافات
تحديدا حين انتقد بين جانس نتنياهو ضمنيا
وقال هذا ليس ثمن افتعال مشكلات لانه
نتنياهو كان يقول انه الوحيد القادر على
على رفض المطالب الامريكيه يعني كان مهتما
بنشر مزيد من الدعايه الشخصيه لنفسه حتى
على حساب الدماء الاسرائيليه
والفلسطينيه كيف يدخل العمل الامريكي الان
وكيف يدخل العمل الامريكي الان مع هذه
المعطيات حتى مع وجود هذه الاشارات
المتواضعه داخل هذه حكومه مجلس
الحرب هل باتجاه هل باتجاه انجاز صفقه ام
باتجاه اكمال العمليات بطريقه ثانيه ام
ماذا
اعتقد لا اعتراض جوهريا بين في الموقف
الامريكي على الحرب ولا على مدتها نحن كنا
سمعنا اعتراضات على مده الحرب
وعلى سؤال ما بعد الحرب كيف سدار قطاع غزه
بعد الحرب اعتقد ان الامريكيين الان
يهدفون الى تحسين الاداء الاسرائيلي وليس
الى وقف حرب الاباده يعني تعديل الاداء
بمعنى المزيد من الدقه واختيار الاهداف
دون ما ان ان تفتح اسرائيل وامريكا على
نفسها انتقادات دوليه واسعه وانتقادات حتى
امريكيه واسعه على الاستهداف المفرط
للمدنيين والاستخدام الشديد لهذه القوه
وبالتالي اعتقد ان الموقف الامريكي يحاول
ان يلفت انتباه الاسرائيليين الى الابعاد
التي ستتل الحرب والتي يمكن ان تنعكس
باثار بالغه الضرر على اسرائيل ومكانتها
وسمعتها وفرص اندماجها في الاقليم وحتى
فرص التطبيع مع مزيد من الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه ا شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله
سيد نهاد ابوغوش الخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي